waiting dilemmas should you split the
bill
on the first date go to eight news now
and twitter and tell us what you think
the results at five
not in my generation kirsten right i
remember being
broke as a joke and i had to pay i was
like
credit card please no i didn't know you
had another choice
i don't think i ever split a bill well
brian before we uh let you go okay we
all wanted to wish you a very happy
birthday here at channel 8 all your
friends
and as part of a birthday surprise your
brother dan reached out
has a special someone sending you the
following greeting
hey brian this is ryan sandberg chicago
cubs hall of famer
former second baseman you know
who i am i think you recognize this face
holy cow center field and deep this is a
tie ball game
you've been a lifelong rhino fan uh
throughout your life and a cubs fan i
appreciate that very much
46 years old happy birthday to you
um and uh
now you're an anchorman in vegas so i
hope everything's well out there
did ryan sandberg just say my name that
was
fantastic i read his book as a kid he
was one of my childhood heroes
rhino ryan sandberg holy cow my brother
dan
well he's awesome and i got to give him
a special thanks for that that was too
cool
you guys knew about this i see everybody
in here about this everybody behind the
scenes too
and of course the managers and of course
your family because they're recording
this from home so oh my god
happy birthday brian thank you so much
you guys all made my day
and thank you rhino chris